this is a production of cornell
university
thank you neil
it's a pleasure to be here it's uh
i sort of consider cornell to be you
know one of the pillars one of the
origins of horticulture in the united
states so it's
it's wonderful to be here
and this is kind of an interesting
anomaly i i don't give a lot of talks
about teaching
uh not that i don't like
to give talks about teaching it's just
that most of the time you know we
research scientists aren't invited to
talk about
our teaching stuff we're invited to talk
about our research stuff
and so i'm going to blaze through some
of the various things that that i'm
working on and
so i'm basically going to be
i'll give you a little background about
myself
neil just gave quite a bit of it already
but
i'm going to talk a little bit about my
research and my extension work
and then talk a little bit about our
teaching programs at uc davis that
relate to the plant sciences and
relating to what i'm presenting here
and then with that context i will dive
into talking about the the
the course that i've come to talk to you
about
so some of this you just you just
learned but the core is that uh
i have a number of different things
going on and the first half of my career
was focused pretty much on ornamentals
and now i'm focused more widely
this book on the market serverless
culture is one that michael raviv and i
put together and it's sort of the
definitive guide on
on uh
on in the field of hydroponics and if
you look really really carefully this
guy in the red shirt right there is that
guy right there
do you remember this spot
in colombia
yeah anyway so
i'm sorry i wasn't aware of that yeah
you're
you're you're a
covergirl kind of thing you know
anyway so
um
i do uh i have research and instruction
in as part of my
uh makeup for my position at uc davis
it's 25
for
instruction and research and i have a
big chunk agricultural experiment
station and then a pretty big chunk for
cooperative extension so i actually am a
specialist and connect with the advisors
in in the field
and
so over the years i've done quite a bit
of work with greenhouses and with
nurseries and
in the last few years i've also started
looking at indoor production
people used to talk to me about indoor
production as to whether that might be a
reasonable thing to do and i told them
that was nonsense
people would talk to me about vertical
production and i say that's nonsense
don't go there
it makes no sense and of course now i'm
aiming directly into that direction and
we'll be
doing a lot of things in that field
because actually it's
some interesting things have happened
and so i've got a couple of i'm just
going to
blast a few screens here of some of the
work that that i've been working on
we've been doing a couple of things with
lettuce
uh looking at various facets i've done
some work with strawberries each time i
work with strawberries i swear i will
never work with strawberries again
and
there's
too much political baggage and all this
stuff but anyway we've been we had this
project where we were looking at root
zone temperatures on strawberries
and uh
still looking at orchids in fact uh
for the early part of my career i did a
lot of work with cut flower roses
and i've always wanted to work on
orchids but i could never get any money
due to that work and
so i ended up
finally doing some work with orchids but
largely from the standpoint of trying to
see if we can grow
potted orchids hydroponically
which of course is a completely
oxymoronic thing because our education
to our students about orchids is don't
water them more than once a week because
you will kill them
and indeed if you're going to try to do
orchids hydroponically
you will kill a lot of orchids
but it is possible
and i bet you'd like me to tell you the
secret of that wouldn't you
i've also been working on a photovoltaic
shade house this is a nursery structure
in california every outdoor nursery has
a screen house maybe even several screen
house at different levels of shading
and i decided that it would make good
sense to do one that instead of throwing
the sunlight away
make it into electricity so this house i
have one section that makes takes 70
percent of the intercepted light makes
electricity
30 of sunlight goes through the plants
and another section where the
is roughly reversed i get about 35
shading and that makes electricity and
then the other portion the plants get
the sunlight and
so this is a my photo will take shade
house and if you ever want to come to
davis and visit you should probably sign
up to visit that
you would not be the only one visiting
that i have also become a tour guide
and
once a week at least i give a tour of
the shade house to whoever wants to come
see it
and
so it's a very it's a very catchy very
eye-catching thing and actually you're
going to see in a minute that i'm going
to make it even more eye-catching this
is the structure it's it's actually one
of the largest things i've ever built at
uc davis
it's the only thing that i've ever had
to do a research project where i had to
buy a power pole
it's a kind of a interesting thing but i
needed to connect my
photovoltaic production to the grid so
that the electricity could go somewhere
because i had no other use for the
electricity myself as you may be aware
in uh container nursery production you
really don't have a lot of use for
electricity you need a little bit to run
the timers and maybe some pumps for
irrigation but beyond that
we don't use it
so that also spurred in my mind a number
of ideas about the fact that well if you
have this kind of a thing and you have
the electricity right there then there
are some other things you can do with
that
so i've actually installed some screen
compartments in there with the idea of
actually doing some cooling in those
screen compartments because i have
electricity
to do that with
and
right now i'm also doing a lot of work
with
plant production lighting
looking at supplemental lighting in a
variety of ways photoperiodic lighting
and particularly looking at the new
technologies that are coming on the
market right now and have been coming on
the market i'm particularly fascinated
with led lighting because i can get
monochromatic lighting or sort of
monochromatic lighting
and suddenly we are starting to see
things that we've never seen before in
horticulture in terms of what we can do
with with that information
so led lighting for those of you who are
not familiar with the concept
stands for light emitting diodes
these are
now you know almost everywhere you can
see them
and the key facet to them is that the
prices have been coming down on them
they were initially touted as being more
energy efficient than light bulbs than
other kinds of light sources but this
was kind of a myth
but one of the big facets to led
lighting is that we can actually
construct a spectrum for that we want to
deliver to the plants so that we can
leave out things that the plants
technically don't need or we think that
the plants might not need so we can make
a lamp that makes absolutely no green
light we can make a lamp that makes no
infrared light and you know
so
and because we have sort of a unique
situation with this device in that all
the light comes off one side of the
device
and heat goes off both the back and the
front you can actually take the heat
off the back and you can channel that
heat away without obstructing the light
itself you cannot do that with
conventional light bulbs
and when you see people in in growth
environments where they have growth
rooms
with hid lamps generally there's a big
effort to try to get all that heat
channeled off
so it doesn't get down to your plants
with led lights you can hold your hand
under the led light you will not feel
any warmth from the lamp
so
that's a kind of unique feature and
there are actually some other unique
features that led lamps also have
and so this is one of the things that
i'm particularly focused on trying to
look at
initially this technology has been
focused primarily on replacing hid lamps
i think that's actually a mistake i
think the hid lamps are great they do a
great job in the greenhouse and if you
hang led lamps in their place
thinking that you've going to replace
the hid lamps you're going to have to do
some very special engineering to get the
money back because right now those are
much much more expensive
and the return on investment is
significantly lower
but if you do it a certain way and you
can
structure it so it's very plant centric
then you will have low lower energy
usage and
and you are then able to do some things
that you can't do with hid lamps such as
switching them on and off very fast
and
right now if you try to switch an hid
lamp on and off well you once you switch
it off you're going to wait 15 minutes
for it to come back fully on
and and in fact you'll wear out the lamp
really fast if you switch it on and off
well solid state lighting doesn't work
that way you can switch it on and off
very rapidly especially if it's designed
that way
so i've got a number of different things
that i'm looking at there and
one of the things is looking at whether
we can use
lighting to control various things on
plants in this case we are orchids and
we're looking at the spike length on
orchids and we really see a very
dramatic difference between orchids
growing under blue light and orchids
growing under red light with the red
light being much more favorable to spike
elongation
on the other hand we can i'm figuring
that we can use the blue light to keep
plants short but i haven't found a way
yet to do that in a reliable fashion
currently i'm building a plant growth
facility
which is an indoor
plant growing facility and you can see
we're actually building it outdoors it's
sitting right next to my shade house my
photovoltaic array
this is what it looks like today it's
actually now completed from the outside
and right now we're building the inside
and it has eight layers of production
inside it and
we're now no longer talking about
two-dimensional production in a
greenhouse environment but
three-dimensional production
and so it's very much a vertical
production situation
and indeed it consumes a lot of
electricity but i have yet to consume
all the electricity that i'm producing
on my pv so if anybody wants to argue
with me about co2 footprint i am yet
taking co2 and making it into biomass
not the other way around
so right now this is gearing up and i
hope to have about 300 some shelf
space areas to work on
so anyway that's kind of my overview of
my
research and
that's all i'm going to say right now
but if you ask me about
some of my research projects later on
i'm obviously happy to talk about them
but my mission here today
is to talk about some teaching things
and
in particular i want to do that in the
context of how we do undergraduate and
graduate education at uc davis we do
have a plant sciences program and plant
sciences at uc davis is the
emerging of four different departments
we actually should have merged five
departments but we
one of them they had too much money and
too much
good stuff they didn't want to dilute
that by letting sharing that with
environmental horticulture and
the other three departments veg crops
agronomy and range science and pharmacy
they agreed that we should form one team
and in fact it was driven by teaching we
we realized that our weakness at uc
davis was our undergraduate teaching in
the plant sciences
and this is despite the fact that we
know that we are the number one plant
biology undergraduate teaching program
in the country okay so in our mind you
might think this can't possibly be but
in our mind the plant sciences part was
defective while the plant biology was
you know nationally number one
and we figured that in order to get our
plant sciences teaching up to that level
we had to make a change and that change
motivated us to
to unite into one program
so today we have programs that range
from molecular genomics genetics all the
way up to ecology
we certainly do physiology in biology
and in horticulture we have
uh some we certainly have a lot of
production horticulture but also
landscape and urban horticulture
the undergraduate majors that we have we
have one called environmental
horticulture and urban forestry this is
basically ornamental horticulture with a
name that nobody can find in the catalog
but
enough students keep finding it year
after year where it's a sustained major
with about 40 students in it at any one
point in time and we decided that we
would not take it apart and merge it
into something else we have started a
plant sciences undergraduate major some
of you might remember that uc davis used
to have a plant sciences undergraduate
major back in the 1980s and 1990s
and well we disassembled that because we
thought that we
didn't need to do that anymore
and then
but then now that we're plant sciences
department we've put that
teaching back on the books
we have related majors we have an
undergraduate major in plant biology we
have a biotechnology major that has
three components with plants being one
of those we have sustainable agriculture
as a brand new major
and
and then on the graduate program side we
have the horticulture and agronomy
graduate group
so that's actually where i take most of
my
graduate students we have a plant
biology graduate group which is actually
where neil got his phd
we also have an ecology
graduate program and a genetics graduate
program and those have those all have
phd programs as part of them
the
the plant sciences i believe is right
now in the 20s 30s something like that
growing because it started brand new it
didn't have any track record and now
it's it's accumulating students
the sustainable agriculture is about the
same size and also growing the biotech
is in the hundreds
and the plant side of that is actually
not
the biggest chunk of that so but there
are typically somewhere between 50 and
70 students in the biotech side
that are plan focused yeah
so there's there's actually quite a
diversity of what an undergraduate
student can get and
we actually specifically uh decided to
leave it that way because i think that
is the best way to meet the the needs of
the students
so my courses that i teach i teach
greenhouse and nursery production i just
got through teaching that winter quarter
our winter quarter ended last week
and
traditionally that has focused primarily
on
ornamentals because that's what in
california is mostly the greenhouse
industry
but i'm starting to put more in on
hydroponics and on vegetable production
because we're seeing some growth in that
area
i teach a graduate course on modeling
modeling horticultural systems and then
this course that i'm going to talk to
you about here today called flower power
and
so it's three courses and if you've kept
tabs on my teaching appointment that is
a success for failure if somebody with
25 teaching teaches this much stuff
and indeed it's been a pretty tough
road and it is a road i'm on because i
choose to be on this road
and so i like teaching
and despite the fact that i don't have
enough inr for it i i do it and uh
i would love to say my colleagues
tolerate it but i actually i don't think
they
they do so
so let's talk about the course i'm here
to talk to you about this is this is
actually the title the title of the
course flower power the application of
the art and science of the beauty and
perfection of flowers
doesn't that make you want to take the
course
i i've told people this on airplanes
sitting next to me and they said oh can
i take that course
do you do an online version
and uh so
you're you're seeing the power of
marketing right here right now your
personal feelings should have somehow
just sort of
popped up a little bit saying i got to
take that yeah
and so what i usually tell people is
well you have to be a student okay
preferably an undergraduate student we
don't well
anyway so
i want to talk to you about how this
course came about because this was not
dictated by any major by anybody nobody
said we need this course taught could
you teach it
this course i invented this course and i
invented it
on the path that i'm going to show you
here
so in 2007 i was doing a project for the
usda foreign act service
and this was a project to do a week-long
workshop of on flower production in
montenegro
so
the question
first question i have to ask you do you
know where montenegro is do you even
know is that a country or a city or
unfortunately some people think it's a
continent but no
montenegro is a little country
in the balkans right here where this
arrow is pointing
and
so as such it is a place where
you know americans don't go for the most
part
and europeans go there on vacation
somewhat it is not a particularly
thriving place
and you know what happened there say 20
years ago
yeah
big war
people butchered each other and killed
each other and shot each other up and
people moved around
the former yugoslavia was disintegrating
had disintegrated the serbians were
unhappy with the kosovons and
the montenegrins were stuck in between
because they're right between the two
sort of
and so this is a place of war and
when i started looking at this in 2007
i was i found myself being asked to go
there and when i asked well why is the
usda doing this
i said well we're collaborating with the
department of state because we need to
try to get that place to be peaceful
and in order to get the place to be
peaceful we need to boost their capacity
in all areas of agriculture all areas of
science whatever we can do the more we
can boost it the more these people
understand that it's better to not be at
war than
to
kill each other over what little they do
have
so
as i was leaving
to fly over there
my wife gave me a book
and this is the book she gave me and she
said i ought to read this book
and i was thinking yeah yeah yeah honey
i don't read books i don't have time for
that
but on the plane you know with nothing
better to do okay sometimes i actually
read a book
and so as i opened the book on the plane
i had a bit of a revelation
and
in particular i knew the main characters
so this is actually the very first bit
of text in the book you know
introduction what's the first thing a
person does when you hand them flowers
bob let's go general manager of the san
francisco flower market asked me
i'm thinking i know bob
okay
and this is bob okay
so and it's me standing with bob on one
of our student field trips actually and
so i'm looking at this thing and said
whoa yeah i'm reading a book you know
published book new york times
best-selling book
and i know the character on the page one
okay and as i keep reading through it i
find more and more characters you know
that i know
and you can go through i'm not going to
read all this for you but in my class
this is actually how i open up
the class i tell them exactly what i've
just told you how the class came about
and i actually read them this out loud
hopefully then when they go off and have
to do their reading they will already
sort of be sucked into this
world and will
will read it
so the book is by amy stewart it's an
expose on the flower industry
and
you know fundamentally between those of
us those of us who do floor culture
we've been to all the places she visited
as part of her research we've seen it
all we've seen the colombians the
ecuadorians the dutch the asians all
these things she talks about
and so for me it's like oh this would be
a great freshman seminar kind of course
where i could you know essentially i can
use this book as the course outline i
don't have to do any work to design the
thing you know and basically at each
chapter that they go through one chapter
per week i would just show them my
slides
from visiting those places and the
people and you know this would be great
students would love that you know so
anyway so i figured it'd be a really
easy course to put together and um so on
the flight back from montenegro i
sketched out the entire thing and when
when i got back to davis i proposed it
as a freshman seminar the administration
liked it and we offered it
and the freshman seminar style course at
uc davis is a 15 max enrollment course
to me that's kind of like oh man do i
want to do that much work for 15
students
well
i said okay i'll try it whatever anyway
particularly because i figured i didn't
have to do any work really i just get up
there pull out my slide sets and you
know step through them and whatever
anyway so
anyway so i arrive at the first day of
class
and there are 40 students
now this is impossible because this is a
conference room type room which is not
in
the catalog okay so you actually had to
have registered for this to know where
the room was
okay
and only 15 people
were actually registered
but 40 were sitting in the room
and i said well what the heck are
all of you doing here 25 of you are in
the wrong room
and i said no no no no no i'm i'm on the
waiting list i said i don't have a
waiting list oh yeah there's a waiting
list and indeed there were 10 people on
the waiting list so these 10 people on
the waiting list were waiting for
people to not take the class okay people
to drop so they could slide it
and the rest were waiting to get on the
waiting list
this was a sign of things to come
because
i i can tell you this course has done
some really weird things that i've never
seen any other course do
so
the first thing i did after i thought as
a freshman seminar decided well this
doesn't this has nothing to do with
freshmen this doesn't need to be for
freshmen only this good you know anybody
should be able to take this anybody
that's has an interest in flowers
and so i turn it into a special topics
course
and it quickly filled whatever room i
picked so i had first time i had a room
that took like 50 seats and 50 students
showed up next time i took a classroom
had 128 seats
128 students showed up so it filled the
capacity of every room i tried
and
it's basically a course that's
specifically designed to give students
what they want
and on account of that it has
word of mouth
appeal
in addition to having this
flower appeal okay
and the key that i was trying to do with
this course is construct a course in
such a way that it would give students
the things they need at the time when
they're registering because that's when
they're signing up for courses and one
thing that a lot of students need they
need a small few units to fill out a
schedule okay and they don't want this
filler
to be some heavy-duty
organic chemistry course okay in fact
they want the exact opposite of an
organic chemistry course okay
which by the way in case you didn't
notice this is probably why horticulture
students come to horticulture because
they figure they can get away from some
of these other courses that are a little
difficult
they want an interesting material no
stress they want to be useful
and as such they prefer to have passed
no pass grading
i also learned that many of them would
have liked to have this course be
general ed but general light is a lot of
work okay that means i got to great
papers and do writing and i said yeah
let's try it without that see if we get
enough people
and
and they want it as a compact place in
the schedule late afternoon this is this
is now a filler for their schedule it
needs to come at a time not in the
mornings when all these other courses
are conflicting with each other but late
in the afternoon so i built this exactly
to that specification
and that's what the course is today
and i have absolutely no problem with
this being a filler because to me
as long as they're paying their
registration and the money somehow
trickles down to where it needs to go i
get paid either way whether the student
is
in my major or not or whether it's a
heavy-duty science course or not it
makes no difference from the standpoint
of
of
and and you know it's up to the student
if they don't want to take it they don't
have to take it there's no this is not
required in any major
it is a
accessible
to any major and actually it has science
content so in many majors it counts for
the science
in that major
so
so it's now a regular uc davis course
it's called plant science six that is
our designated number it is designed as
a survey of floor culture two units past
no pass it runs ten weeks one late
afternoon meeting per week usually
tuesday afternoons in the most
comfortable lecture hall i can find
has to have nice padded seats has to be
comfortable it has to be the kind of
thing where on tuesday afternoon at 4
o'clock when they come in they sit down
and they let
i'm here
so
with that
this is a destination it's a destination
during the week and i can tell you the
students come
so i also do
just a little bit of testing with the
multiple choice questions they're not
difficult exams there are and because
it's passed no pass they are
well they they can usually pass without
doing a lot
so spring 2013 enrollment was 170.
and then that classroom became too full
i decided well let's go for a bigger
room i found another lecture all had 370
369 seats and last year i had 300
students
currently enrollment is at 360.
nine more probably by now and it will
have a waiting list and this waiting
list will probably be
40 students long
in the course of spring first few days
of spring quarter i will lose probably
50 of these students
okay because it's by design it's a
filler in their schedule they have
something there a lot of students park
something there because they can't find
something else okay so this is parked
there now some students end up with it
there particularly after the first day
of lecture
but a lot of students drop it because
they need something else they have you
know they've got to do their major stuff
but if i have a fairly long waiting list
it'll all still shuffle in and then i
end up with a class that's nearly full
i'm expecting 2015 my enrollment to be
about 350
at the end it's probably what it's going
to settle down for
so
clearly undergraduate students are
interested in floor culture and this was
actually a bit of a revelation because
up until this point everybody that i
ever talked to about floriculture is oh
this is a minor niche thing students
aren't interested in this students don't
care about this field and
anyway we were wrong
so i'll tell you some of the various
facets that are
embedded into this course it's you know
i talk about how flowers are produced
how the florist gets them the whole
wholesale side of the picture
i teach them some common names of
flowers the whole idea being is that if
they're going to go into flower shop and
buy flowers they got to know what
they're buying okay it's like if they're
going to go buy a cd they need to know
the bands okay and they need to know
them by their used names
not by their latin names so i give them
latin names also sometimes but i'm
primarily interested in learning the
common names
and then how to handle them you know we
know a lot about post post service
handling and
a lot of that i you know they get a
lecture on how to do the post service
handling
they get some facets of the science
about genetically modified organisms
about botany plant biology horticulture
and flora culture but that's kind of a
toned down part it's woven enough into
it to hopefully generate some interest
among them so some of them might
actually take our other plant science
courses
then of course the reading is the and
discussion is centered around uh the
book flower confidential
and
so indeed i do exactly as what i
initially planned i do a lot of various
things that you know seem
fluffy you know
trust me it's fluffy
fluffy by design you know it's like a
great doughnut you know i was like don't
tell me you don't like great doughnuts
you know it's like it's fluff
we have art in there i mean art after
all is in the title okay all i forgot to
tell you is when i tried to get that
title through the courses committee they
said no no you can't have that title
that title is too long
here's what here's the title of this
book this is flowers and their uses
uh
okay
thank god for word of mouth you know
that i don't have to count on somebody
actually looking in the catalog
to be marketed my course to okay
anyway so
i use this title i always use this title
and anyway it has art in the title
and so the students do an art project
and in fact they uh
these are some of the examples we have
them do a little panel
for with a with a letter of their choice
initially they had to use the first
letter of their last name
and but they then have to find a flower
look it up find out what it actually
looks like and give me some art some
original art
and they have to do it in this
particular format because i have other
uses for this particular art because as
you see i have letters i can spell
interesting things with what they give
me
so this is one of the projects and
there's always a few people who just
can't be bothered to do it they're you
know they did that in second grade and
that seems like second great stuff but
okay we do a flower arranging workshop
actually
last year we did nine separate workshops
during one particular week instead of
that week's lecture
so we did actually me and my staff we
did as much work
that entire week that week as the entire
rest of the quarter combined
so i'd love to say i'm never doing that
again but i'm going to do it one more
time this year and i'll you'll see in a
few minutes why
students actually love it okay and i'm
not and you might think ah come on
there's a whole bunch of guys who aren't
going to get into this
not not so okay everybody gets into it
and
actually quite interesting
this particular person right here
you might not be able to tell but this
person is blind
how do you deal with a student with that
kind of disability in a course like this
well guess what it's about flowers
and these flowers to a blind person are
just as potent as to a seeing person
it's just they
sense something different okay
so her bouquet was going to be
she wasn't going to put stuff in and it
doesn't have scent all right she's gonna
anyway so
i learned a bunch of things from this
student i was really happy this student
came on board because i had no clue how
i would teach this material to a blind
person so it was actually
i may have learned more from
watching her
learn the material than than
than i would have thought
then in one lecture i give every student
a flowering pot of plant this happens
about the third week of the quarter
and the student is giving given this
plant
and with the instruction that they have
to make some impact with it
and the first question that
usually comes back is can i make impact
on myself and
what i usually say to this well you're
going to have a writing assignment where
you have to describe what impact you
made with it
and if you want to write about how it
made an impact on you
that's fine but i would caution you that
that might be a little bit more
difficult than giving it to your mother
and your mother
being just exuberant about it or
something like that so anyway they have
to do a writing assignment it's an essay
it's not a particularly long
thing but
there have been some very memorable
essays particularly i still recall one
young asian student who took a white
chrysanthemum to her mother and nearly
got thrown out of the family for doing
so
if you don't know why
then you don't know
then you need to come take the course
because you see
in asian culture you need to understand
what a white chrysanthemum represents
and it has a much more strong
representation in asian culture than
these meanings of flowers have in our
culture and this young lady should have
known better but somehow in her
upbringing that wasn't imprinted on her
but her mother who was chinese was very
much imprinted and had been ill and now
getting this white flower which was
supposed to pepper up
well in that culture the white
chrysanthemum is a funeral flower okay
so
not good but these are the kinds of
essays i'm getting you know at least
some percentage are
like that
so we discuss some very difficult
dilemmas when a friend has a birthday
are flowers worth more than balloons or
chocolates
is it okay to bribe somebody with
flowers
now you might want to think about this
yourself
think about it do you think it's okay
if you want something good to happen
to give somebody flowers
is it okay to do that but it's not okay
to give them money
it's not okay to give them a bottle of
wine or something the flowers you can
get away with things that you can't get
with
any other thing
it's a power tool of extraordinary
proportions
it indeed
this is why the course is called flower
power because flowers in fact have a
power that nothing else around us has
and so
students learn this and
and then of course i try to get in and
get them to think a little bit more than
just the flower itself but looking at
you know colors and patterns and depth
and and you know pot mums versus orchids
and things like that so trying to give
them a sense of value with respect to
the flowers
and
i was actually making a presentation
about this course to
some uh to the board of the american
floral endowment
and i was explaining to them
one thing that these students had told
me and and one thing that i learned from
them is that they would buy flowers
if they had a way to buy them but in
davis the campus is like its own little
city there are no flower shops on campus
if a student wants to get flowers
they've got to go to one of the grocery
stores or to one of the big box stores
and there they can get them but to do
that they got to take a bus
to get there or they're going on their
bicycles
are they going to be lugging flowers on
their bicycles
you see what kind of extraordinary
length a student needs to go through to
do this
whereas for
you know if like if you're going to your
friends those are you not students if
you know if you're a working
adult and you're going to visit some
friends you you know you'd have no
trouble finding flowers you pick them up
on the way there right well
in the hands of the in for these
students they have a difficult time with
this because they don't have good access
and on top of that it's not being
marketed to them at all largely because
the floriculture industry is doesn't see
that they're there they don't see them
as a force in the marketplace so they
don't see it as something that should be
cultured and built up
so
basically what i learned is that the
floriculture industry is simply not
doing a particularly good job to get
flowers into the hands of students
and everyone that i've talked to on the
industry side would tell me
they're not going to buy flowers they're
not buyers of flowers
so anyway one thing that i figured is i
have this very large group 300 some
students
i can do some surveys
and so now
and they're from all cross-sections of
society now okay maybe not all
cross-sectional societies these are
students or college in college
you know probably going into a
particular array into particular
lives where they will have maybe
an above average income
is this a clientele you want to develop
or not in floriculture remember flowers
are
luxury objects
so
anyway the floral endowment was very
interested in seeing data on this so
they've actually funded a project for me
to ask these students and they get the
money into my hands
literally the day before spring quarter
started last quarter so last quarter i
wove a bunch of surveys already in
to it and then this spring quarter
starting basically
in two weeks
i'm going to do the project sort of full
blast and and hit the students with
targeted questions
because i can ask him about consumer
preferences
and
hopefully we can learn how the flower
industry can unlock this market
so for the surveys
i have actually a very interesting tool
already when i take attendance the
students have to come with a scantron
form i don't know if you have scantron
machines here at cornell for us uc davis
maintains a set of scantron machines
which are machines that you can
grade
multiple choice
testing with okay the students have to
have a scantron form to run through the
scantron machine and they cost like a
quarter each or a dime or something like
that they're very cheap
but because i do use those for
attendance already
the student is already using them and i
have a hundred slots where i could ask
questions on them so as long as i can
form my question in the form of a
multiple choice or true false question i
can ask any question i want
now you might think
that that's not true i mean
think about some questions that in a
typical server you cannot ask
are you gay
are you rich
are you poor
how would you ask a question like that
in a conventional survey
i can ask these questions
okay i just have to phrase them cleverly
and i have to give the students
the choice to opt out so they don't
fill out the question
and indeed all these questions that are
not point generating questions the
students know which questions generate
points and which ones don't
but when i make the survey at the very
beginning of the quarter i have already
told them
that this is
nationally funded research they are part
of a nationally funded project
to help college students
have better access to flowers
so they have another motivation to
answer the questions
and they know that i'm not going to
be saying much about it but
each of the
forms has their student id number on
them so week after week i can link all
the surveys
so i have the most incredible database
of information
and i only have to ask the gender
question once i only have to ask the age
question once
because
my database i just keep adding more
tables in and i can link across these
tables
and because otherwise if they don't turn
the form in they don't get their
attendance points
they're pretty much captive they pretty
much have to turn the piece of paper in
how they mark is a different story but
if you've ever done any surveys that's
half the battle is getting the form back
half the battle is having them actually
look at the thing
make a decision but in this case we got
the vast majority of people answering
the questions and
so we had uh some consumer preference
testing on pot roses on
orchids
this was actually an example of how
the survey was being run this is
actually in the classroom we had two
more stations like this in other
adjacent buildings because with 300 some
students
to do have them walk around a table like
this that can take a half an hour so we
sent them out to lots of different
places in
and then on this particular day when
they do this
they also get the pot of plant
okay and the pot of plants
end up in their hands to make flower
impact with
so we get the
in this case we got
two-thirds of these flowers donated a
third we grew ourselves in fact i grew
them in my
greenhouse production class
and and so and then the students had to
actually pony up some cash they had to
make a donation if they were going to
get a
pot rose they had to make a two dollar
donation if they had an orchid they had
to get a five dollar donation
if they weren't willing to make a
donation they could take one of the free
mums that i had grown
which are
pretty nice looking plants also
so
and then in the flower ranging
we do some consumer preference there
also we had the vases donated by
somebody and then we said well we can do
a preference testing on that to see what
students prefer there and so we have you
know 18 different vases students can
show preference we have different
flowers that flower growers donate it to
this cost which of course first we do
the survey then the students can grab
flowers and make
arrangements
we also tried
to analyze the individual bouquets to
see if we could characterize bouquets we
haven't quite finished with doing that
and i'm not sure that this is really
going to work
as yet but basically each student has a
a number
in a particular
workshop you can actually see the part
of lindsay's name there and you can see
some other names there i should have
blotted those out i suppose but the
different bouquets are made by the
different participants they're
photographed and then
set out and then the students go with
their scantron form and do
give us their preferences
and you might think that that would be
an obvious thing but you know students
have special kinds of needs when they're
in a dorm room in a dorm room there
isn't a lot of room okay so a big
bouquet is not necessarily the most
preferred thing you're looking for some
very special features that will make it
work okay
and so this is the kind of thing we're
trying to tease out out here to try to
get
student preferences and the company that
donated
the
the
the plans for this is generally very
happy with the outcome because they've
they've they've kind of seen what they
need to do
here's a few survey results i'm not
going to
tell you the whole story here just give
you maybe two results
this is a the population you can see
this actually represents then the
population of my plant science six class
so yes indeed more
more women than men
but
okay 17 men
and then in age we have a fairly young
demographic
this is something that we're going to
slice and dice a little different next
year i didn't realize i had
so many in that 18 to 20 category i
thought there were
going to be fewer in that but
and then in terms of school year i have
as many
basically the same amount of any any
class out there so it's it's wildly
appealing at all levels
and
um
in terms of consumer preference this is
one example this this particular orchid
you know the students are given the
question
you know
in terms of the five responses they can
make this plan is awesome very
attractive this plan is good i like it i
found it more attractive than average et
cetera et cetera the last one this plant
is not attractive and you can see this
particular
situation here if i look at a different
variety
that's this you can see the pattern is
quite different so this particular
demographic has a very
particular
thing they like better
okay
why that is i don't know it doesn't
matter
but to the company that has these
orchids going out
that can make a big difference what they
send to davis
here's a one question that we asked
regarding access to flowers please mark
all that you consider to be correct
statements
students generally do not buy flowers
it's something this group would not do
even if they had better access to floral
products 18 percent agreed with that
students do buy flowers but not many due
to various reasons including access and
perceived cost 81 answered that you'll
notice this doesn't add to 100 because
they could actually choose multiple of
these as things they agreed with
students would buy significantly more
floor pods if they experience marketing
similar to what they see for candy music
clothes cosmetics toys etc
40 percent
i think for the industry this is very
potent information
they're not doing it right now anybody
says they're doing it is simply not
understanding that they're not doing it
they're not targeting this demographic
at all
and they could and they could sell many
more flowers into this demographic
and then none of the above are correct
statements about students and you see
very few people would
not pick one of those as being something
they will mark
here's another one if we open a flower
shop on campus run by students which of
the following would be
most likely to be profitable now i
should sell this information
clearly i should sell this information
i'm giving it away in typical university
professor style
so
anyway if you want to start a flower
shop at cornell here's your business
model
so oh and notice the last one
none of the above selling floor products
to students would not be profitable
these are the people who would actually
buy it
and
of course by the time this question was
asked they had learned how to make
impact with their flower so this may
have been biased by
you know the course itself for for these
so one of the things that i have to do
differently
next year i have to give a pre-survey
very early on
and then have them come back and do this
again at the end to see how their minds
change
so we now have lots of information like
this and we're going to collect more of
it
so let me just summarize then for
uh
with respect to this flower power course
the
really floor culture information has
very broad appeal amongst college
students
and
it's generally much more than we would
think
and it's been it's been a big surprise
to me
in fact i keep teasing them that
the campus uc davis is currently
building a 600 seat classroom and i
think i'm going to be signing up for
that one
we'll see where my power runs out but it
hasn't run out yet
so it's a very popular course and i
think it's that way because i really aim
it at the needs of the students i'm not
focused on my needs
it's easy for me to do the way i'm doing
it and i like that that certainly is fun
but
it is a boatload of work particularly
with all those plants flowing through
people's hands all those flowers all
those floral products
this massive amount of work if i didn't
have tas i couldn't do it
and
and i'm grateful for the tas that i have
and then you know the fact that the
students are telling us things that are
useful
and uh
i don't do a lot of advertising but i do
some this is one of the ads
this finds its way onto little bulletin
boards outside certain faculty members
office doors strategically placed around
the campus
i've plastered it at the dining commons
on the glass inside the glass door as
they walk in
and students look at it and it's sort of
a universal appeal and then once they
realize what it says
learn to speak the language of flowers
another potent term that
anyway so
i didn't i did initially think that this
course would channel students into our
majors
i don't think that's happened
i not even close
i grabbed essentially student fte
student credit hours that we were not
catching in any other way
and we're never going to see again in
another
plant science course
but
we got them
and hopefully trained them how to use
flowers
with the financial problems we're having
many of our law enrollment courses are
being cancelled so the students are
desperate for alternatives and this is
filling such a void they need they need
things they can put in their schedule
and i'd be surprised if that sort of
thing is not happening here as well
anyway with that that's the material i
wanted to present to you today and i'm
open to questions
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu